Today we explore the concept of mutual assent by examining the case of Emory
versus Harget Dine and some relevant provisions of the uniform commercial code.
Mutual assent describes an agreement between two parties that intend to form a
contract.
Before we take a look at Embry,
let's discuss why mutual assent is such an important concept.
As you know,
parties often have extensive negotiations before signing the contract.
These negotiations happen over time that are subject to the parties choice and
not predetermined by law or a circumstance.
Parties can discuss everything from price,
quantity,
quality,
the method of payment,
which party will bear certain risks,
the d distribution of the relationship,
the duration of their relationship and so forth.
At some point,
the parties will end the negotiations and might agree to be bound by contractual
obligations.
In other words,
they might bring the contract into formal existence.
Freedom from contract is just as important as freedom to contract.
Individuals don't have to be bound by contractual promises unless they want to,
so figuring out whether they want to be bound is important.
As we go through the next few lessons including this one.
Keep in mind this guiding question.
How do courts tell when there's been sufficient agreement to form a contract?
A contract usually is formed when there's mutual assent.
I think of this as the moment the bell rings,
so kind of trans substantiation that changes legal duties of the parties.
Uh,
mutual assent describes the act of agreeing to the terms of the contract.
It's a green to the exchange of promises.
A related concept that is sometimes treated as a synonym is the meeting of the
minds.
Meeting of the minds describes a situation where there is a common understanding
in the formation of the contract,
a common understanding of what has been exchanged.
Phrase differently.
There's a meeting of the minds when both parties agree to the promised exchange.
Mutual assent usually contains two components.
Offer and acceptance offer.
An acceptance are elements that traditionally were required for the formation of
a legally binding contract.
The person who makes an offer is often called the offer roar and the person who
hears and considers the offer is the offeree.
If I ask,
would you like to buy this pen for $50?
I am a an offer making an offer.
You are the offeree.
If you say yes,
then that is an acceptance with both offer and acceptance.
There is also mutual assent.
Uh,
in this example,
the two of us have mutually assented to the contract through the process of
offer and acceptance.
The uniform commercial code which governs the sale of goods has a number of
provisions concerning mutual assent as well as offer and acceptance.
We will now introduce these provisions and they are frequently cited in many of
the cases we will learn so it's good to be familiar with them.
First,
let's look at UCC two two oh four.
It deals with contract formation in general and it states that a contract for a
sale of good can come into being in a variety of ways as long as it's clear that
the parties have reached agreement,
the agreement can be found from conduct or behavior,
so does not always have to be in writing.
The provision also states that agreement is enough to be a contract even if we
don't know when the contract started,
when it was formed.
The timing of a contract can be of crucial importance in some contract disputes.
So it's always helpful to ask when the contract is formed or as I sometimes
think of it when the bell rings.
UCC Two dash two oh five deals with what are called from offers.
If a merchant makes an offer in writing and is explicit that the offer will be
held open,
then the offer is not revokable for a period of up to three months,
uh,
for it's open,
it's going to be held open non revokable for reasonable time but up to three
months.
And in this way the sense of the offer is not revokable,
it's called a firm.
You'll notice that there's no consideration in the case of a firm offer because
the offeree hasn't done anything or paid anything to make the offer from
however,
this provision is explicit that at least a merchant offer or is obliged to keep
affirm oppor offer open for this period of time of up to three months phrased
differently.
A firm offer is an irrevocable offer.
This is an exception to the general rule that most offers can be revoked by the
offer roar bef at any time before they're accepted.
UCC Two two oh six is an unusual default rule which says that an offer invites
acceptance by any reasonable means unless the offer or,
or circumstances unambiguously indicate otherwise.
This suggests that courts require unambiguous evidence to overturn the strong
presumption that offers intend to be acceptable by any reasonable means.
The qualifies the common law idea that the offer or is master of her offer at
common law.
The FN offer roar,
uh,
say,
said something like,
I'll sell you my car for $10,
but you can only accept by sky riding across the sky in New York City law and
economics rocks.
And you respond to this by saying,
thanks,
I accept,
well,
we don't have a contract because you haven't met my conditions for acceptance
and uh,
as master of my offer,
I can condition your acceptance on you doing something crazy like skywriting
under the UCC.
In contrast,
I'd have to be careful as the offer or to unambiguously make skywriting the only
means of accepting the contract.
Okay?
We just went through three very important provisions of the uniform commercial
code.
It's okay if you're confused or didn't keep track of everything perfectly.
Let's answer two questions to review.
Number one,
I offer you a pen for $100 and you nod and pay me the hundred dollars and take
the pen.
Do we have a contract and which section of the UCC applies?
Okay,
well,
the answer is this is a valid contract.
UCC Two,
two Oh four states that conduct is sufficient for agreement.
All right.
Number two,
a merchant posts an ad to sell a pen for $100 and states the offer is good until
next Friday.
You show up on Tuesday and the merchant has raised the price to $120 what price
are you supposed to pay and which section of the UCC applies?
Well,
the answer is that you should be able to buy the pen for $100.
And the merchant made a firm offer and is bound by that under UCC two two oh
five.
Let's turn now to the case of Embry versus Harget dine in this case.
Embry,
the plaintiff is an employee of the defendant Harget dine Embry told the
president of the company that he would quit his job if he were not given an,
uh,
a renewed employment contract for the following year.
According to the plaintiff,
the president replied,
quote,
go ahead your all right.
Get your men out and don't let that worry you unquote.
At this point,
the plaintiff believed he had an employment contract.
The president argues he never intended for this to be a contract and plaintiff
was an employee at will throughout this period that could an employee at will as
somebody that can be hot fired for good,
bad or no reason.
When employment was terminated early,
the plaintiff sued for breach of contract.
The trial judge instructed the jury that defined for plaintiff,
they had to find both that the president uttered the aforementioned phrase and
that both parties intended by having such conversation to contract for
plaintiffs reemployment,
the jury found for the defendant and the instant court reversed and remanded
defined out what words were actually used by the employer.
So is this an implied in fact or an express contract?
Okay.
While not the main focus of the opinion,
note that this case lies somewhere in the middle of the spectrum between implied
in fact contracts and express contracts.
Uh,
the employer did not express Lee say that he was a rehiring Embry.
So it's probably better to think of this as an implied in fact contract that is
words and conduct,
if anything suggested or implied a promise.
So under the plaintiff's theory of the case,
who is the offer here?
Well,
the answer is that the plaintiff Embry is the offer who offered to be rehired
for another year,
presumably at the same rate of pay.
And under the plaintiff's theory Harget Diane accepted the offer by saying,
go ahead.
You're all right.
Get your men out,
et cetera.
The main issue in this case is this.
If the plaintiff was reasonable and interpreting defendant's behavior,
uh,
is it still necessary for the defendant to have an intention to contract for the
contract to exist?
Or in other words,
is it what you say or what a reasonable listener would have understood you to
mean?
That determines whether a contract exists?
The court held that it is not necessary for the defendant to have an intention
to contract.
What matters is the expressed intention,
although a meeting of the minds is the usual requirement of contract formation,
plaintiffs will be held to their expressed intention even if they secretly
harbored contrary thoughts.
The court is clear that it's really the objective manifestation of consent that
controls what the speaker is subjectively meant or what the listener
subjectively believed the speaker to mean.
Doesn't count parties that intend but don't manifest.
Don't have a contract parties that don't intend but do manifest,
do have a contract.
Okay.
Evaluating People's objective.
Manifestation of intent might make a lot of sense at first.
Imagine if you agree to a contract,
but cross your fingers behind your back.
We certainly don't want you to be led out of the contract.
That would be a gross.
However,
the reasonable person standard that the court adopts can create a lot of
ambiguity.
The court says that the plaintiff's version of events,
if true,
was sufficient to be taken by any reasonable person as an assent to the demand.
Do you think that's really true?
Some might view the president's speech is a polite brush off rather than the
offer or the acceptance of the uh,
employees offer.
Also notice that the court took the decision away from the jury.
It found that the issue as a matter of law,
because no reasonable juror could find differently.
This seems quite an extreme position to take given the ambiguity in what the
president actually said.
Today we examine the question of mutual assent.
Mutual assent describes an agreement between two parties to create a contract
and is a necessary condition of most contracting.
We took a look at important provisions in the uniform commercial code,
which we will encounter many more times in the rest of this course.
The provisions defined offers and acceptance and when they constitute the
formation of a contract.
Finally,
we discussed the Embry case,
which held that the test for agreement is the objective reasonable listener.